dovrete indovinare se uno slide mosse 1
squizzi noi non abbiamo ancora visto i
video quindi andremo a indovinare
assieme a voi vediamo chi fa più punti
tra me e vitale e anche voi nei commenti
dovrete scrivere le vostre risposte alla
fine del video vediamo se avete vinto
voi o se ho vinto io con contro da
alessi ritenete il conto dei punti siete
pronti lasciato bellezze volete vedere
altre challenge genere mettetevi comodi
boccone
pare che il loro è uno switch o uno
slide strisce che secondo me erano
scrissi non penso proprio che sia uno
stand scrivete voi la vostra risposta
numero uno squeeze slime vediamo si fa
uno che carina questa squisita l'altro
bene una pecora ma come me è questo qui
se uno slide ma non lo scrisse che
questo sì magari si sorprendono lo
stesso conosci vi sembrano squizzi
scrivete voi nei commenti riguardo il
quiz live vediamo finì 2 a 2
che carino non a tre è uno squeeze to1
slime secondo me ora strisce secondo me
è uno slider troppo perfetto per essere
uno slider 1 strisce però mi sembra
lusso mi sembra schiuma no e scrivete
voi numero treni come gli slums qui si
vediamo tutto
infatti era perfetto era fatto benissimo
ci credo al numero 4 quindi noi siamo 22
così potrei a 26 mag
quindi questo è il numero quattro quest
lime scurisce i decisamente dire qui si
è bellissimo tra l'altro lo vorrei anche
a questo scritto proprio squish scrivete
nei commenti
meno male che bene numero 5 è ai box qui
sì questo è un host line il fatto che
sia dentro una ciotola con il cucchiaino
dentro decisamente direi live come lo
chiama anche la giocolano la descrisse
ti mazzini ma anche cocaina tutto
no non penso no io dico slide vediamo
[Musica]
sembra che fate con cereali che ben
oppure fico difficile numero 6
james clichy secondo me questo è uno
swipe perché vedi che arrotolato infatti
dentro sembra che ci sia un club di
slime dentro il macaron però la parte di
fuori è troppo perfetta
sembra quasi lo scrissi io dico squisito
de macedo dice che scurisce fuori isla
dentro
no io dico slime tutto slime voi
scrivete nei commenti questo numero dei
video anche se non posso darle euro e
forti per 8 ma si capiva bellissimo
questo non cassette questo credo sia
proprio uno switch sì direi anche che
uno squeeze i questo sanremo scrive
abbiamo perso il conto dei punti in
viaggio tubero astir mero proposta nome
in dominato quindi siamo fare diciamo
pari di confusa e loro bellissimo top
canio uomo
zero latino numero 8 questo è difficile
fly mood qui sì io ti costruisci questo
è difficile però cosa mette in effetti
sì direi squish non ne sono sicura però
qui c voi cosa dite dynos qui si vediamo
ha imbrogliato 9 numero 9 abbiamo
conakry ma il cioccolato secondo me
questo molto ai moti anche secondo me il
fatto che sia così lucido sembra un po
uno squisito è un bradipo direi uno slap
sotto sembra tipo batte slime sopra uno
slide normalmente qui si vediamo
comunque sono fatti benissimo numero 10
questo veramente difficile laimo scrissi
lo sa io non so proprio decidere sembra
fosse uno squeeze però ha qualcosa
sembra sembra fatto ma non russo io dico
strisci sì anch'io di costruirsi se uno
dei propri sorprenderò tantissimo voi
cosa dite fly box qui ci vediamo ti
scrissi
spero che per render trend squeeze il
cibo vero numero 11 di terlago scrisse
fatto benissimo
sarà così preciso dire digos crisci poi
non lo so se mi sbaglio perché mi sa che
le immagini sul loro sono differenti non
saranno secondo voi cosa dite io dico
online
io dico squish
occorre che lo stato che lo stampino
sicuramente anche questa sera la tortina
proprio tutto è così che dovrebbe essere
e cibo vero o il padre di reis qui ci
stiamo al numero 11 11 oddio veramente
difficile perché non mi sembra proprio
slide questa parte sopra mano che non
sia uno slang cucinato non quello tutto
potrebbe essere fatta però sono mosso
squisita ecco io pur di costruire
qualcosa di te
vediamo no era giusto lo slime come ha
fatto fare la parola di ora ma anche un
po bruciata no vabbè incredibile ti
assurto a questo si vede dai facilissimo
si capisce uno scrittore o magari è uno
slam
rimaniamo tutti scioccati vediamo che
bello questo è un biscottino il gelato
riscosso numero 13 13 forse sempre
portiamo il conto
direi che è uno squeeze sangue dice da
noi che dite vediamo ora grandissima
partita bellissima vivere
qui si no 14 signore la mia parrucchiera
cos'hai in testa ma ciliegia una fragola
sistema fragola inter
beh direi che questo è uno scritto di
fermo e cos'ha detto che numero 14 15
qui si slime questo slime slime suoi
perché sembra che sia stato fatto con il
clay che comunque incredibile perché
quanto è il bersaglio
i dettagli sono perfetti e bellissimo
incredibile
voi cosa dite slime scrissi vediamo
subito mi dispiace caro a noi stessi
perché non si distruggeva ebbero è
strano perché sono molto molto duri
quindi immagino svegliamo lei molto
molto play e poco slime ecco vedi ora ha
aggiunto lo spray troppo bello questo mi
dispiaceva mi ha risposto sulla flacca
di temi e un orsetto numero 16
l'aima scrissi allora ci abbiamo un
pezzetto con il qb tifoso fini secondo
me caslam questi anche dire in sé ma
anche se non riesco a capire come fanno
a fare le sfumature vedi sembra proprio
un biscotto che è stato solo conto al
collo oppure qua incredibile sono
brevissimi
se questo abete il segreto spiegazioni
commenti magari in un video proprio
farlane che vi sia un disastro farò mi
faccio veneto vi fa niente che già non
mi faccio dire che prima tutti scrivete
voi di come di sligo scrissi e dico
slide si slime ok vediamo ha aggiunto la
sequenza dei è comunque spline macerie
mi dispiace ma fragola sempre numero 17
lines qui sixt line
si contatta da un tag lei sì sembra
quasi fatto con con la plastilina di voi
cosa dite lo scrissi vediamo un minor
ritoccarlo ha detto scusate
ogni volta che accendiamo la telecamera
per registrare i vicini impartiscono e
quando voleva fare il caos più totale
ambulanze polizia tutti assieme sono lì
aspettando acquisti switch ti direi
squizzi voi cosa dite
vediamo che bello betto qui che è fidato
e lo scrissi più grande al mondo i primi
io penso che siamo stanchi
penso che siano scurisce insieme e non
ho mai visto switch così grado così o
meglio sono spesi così grande ma car
home tv è un dolcetto giapponese
assicura io voglio vedere acquistare
tutto questo io mi si chiede restò brano
frate cappuccino questo comodissimo
vediamo corsi bellissimo non voglio
ditemi che lo posso comprare questi qua
allora prossimo in questo caso potrebbe
essere uno squeeze potrebbe essere uno
slam
potrebbe essere uno switch slime cosa è
si potrebbe anche essere entrambi quindi
io dico qui sì io pure solo squish
immediato che scurisce crisi
sono veramente di tutti i tipi di
scritti sono troppo cari non so cosa il
legno o entrambi media qui si giusto
perché ci portachiave attaccato dai
falli e anche anche perché poi sono
colorati tutti perfetti allo stesso
punto quindi si scurisce crisi questo è
facile ei crisi interessante questo
squeezes laimo entrambi all i controlli
la penske e siano scrissi le fragole qui
ci penso che sia la parte di sotto e
dentro la crema e le fragole sono slime
effetti come hanno fatto a fare questa
parte quali stai
io vi dico tutto slime mi butto vediamo
voi cosa dite questo è difficile
comunque a parte che sembra vero anche
questo che sta venendo un pub
vediamo è fatto benissimo prossimo che
fa voglino carinissimo io fosse molto
difficle da solo slime secondo me sono
slime io ti costruisci anche se è
difficile questo potrebbe stimare se non
so anche uno squisito lidi costruisci
slime vediamo
il marito tutto tra l'altro la parte di
sopra forse era per quello che dava da
fare è una forma quasi perfetta acquisì
slam o entrambi
questo è solo strisci secondo me non
sono scorsi sono dei pallini quater
può sembrare quell'effetto clay prassi
come già visto questo tipo di scurissimo
dumpling penso che sia uno scrissi
vediamo mio solo scurisce slime è uno
switch slime si intendono quelli qui si
chiama lo slime dentro sqlite sulla
legge wineline non si fosse cose
veramente
bandiamo questa parola diciamo scribe
secondo voi cosa sono questi klein con
la cui rischiano slime dentro o un altro
tipo di crisi e scrivete nei commenti
comunque ma poi perdono la forma sacello
slime dentro non sono semplicemente più
morbidi lento beh facile direi squish
osk lines no squish i knicks crimes and
the vediamo un giorno scribe non so
quale sia la differenza però
grandissimo e bellissima no io spero che
sia uno squeeze in uno slam of the line
sì mi sembra uno slide però mi dispiace
troppo che miri distrutta sicuramente
sarà uno slice sì dico slime voi cosa
dite
vediamo non di distruggere e troppo
ballo si è andato toglie loro affetto
che si è capottato rampi secondo la non
si vede neanche molto bene qui in questo
avrà uno swipe io dico che uno squeeze
voi cosa dite una squadra il disco i'm
alive
ma perché metto nessuno lo slime ma
questo è difficile
scrisse slime offline però sembra quasi
fatto a mano
forse un host line e nico scrissi mi
sembra troppo perfetto io dico slide
vediamo io ballo incredibile bellissimo
oggi io un panino sembra vero qui sisley
most lime tutte e due
klein forse sì secondo me l'infame tipo
scrissi e dentro e uno slime tipo
vediamo ma devo incidere dopo tanto
fanno così perfetto
e incredibile veramente credere uno
script questo è troppo facile
il cosino per appenderlo quindi diremmo
uno direi scrissi così anche questo c'è
la fregatura del casinò per appenderlo
qui si no reale come cavolo fauno quanto
tempo ci mettono a farli veramente io
direi che ha visto che abbiamo visto
quello di prima gara ha fatto così bene
[Musica]
ha solo alla quantità di dettagli e
incredibile ma si mostri slam
entrambi fly meglio e si visto che ho
visto come sono fatti bene splendide ora
di cosa perché sto da un lato il gelato
quello peste
non lo credo che quello c'è novecento il
paese non c'è pace dentro però a forma
di peso non credo del cono
abbiamo preso una volta ci si è
sbriciolato tutto adotta la cosa più
scomoda al mondo che conoscono il cono
normale vi aggiorno dimesso cioè stanno
troppo brava incredibile questo
difficile difficile difficile
qui ci sono entrambi entrambi in effetti
la favola sembra troppo perfetta schlein
suoi casa virtus line perché ho fatto la
fragola ricordo io coltiverò perché non
franco beh questo è facile
qui si gigante si attesta invece sto
pensando la seguo asp lime
però effettivamente si pensa siano
scrissi perché troppo grande e bello
specie considerando dove si comprano di
te però non ne ho mai visti col pop
corrida la nocciolina già schiacciando
comunque direi che uno squeeze visto che
c'è la pena ultimo ultimo quindi stiamo
attenti suisses laimo entrambi secondo
me qui è in effetti un po diverso c'è è
fatto meglio lo slime che è fatto a mano
è più realistico che lo scrissi perché
questo non lo so dipinto un po male ma
non esaurisce mai che cos'è quella cosa
bianca cioè c'è tornate la lattuga o in
forma della sea
qui si ma non c'è più la parte bianca
[Musica]
chakwal quadra che non cosa ho visto per
quanti quotiamo inter fatto noi
ovviamente abbiamo perso il cotto come
sempre
penso che ho vinto io ma non so forse
stiamo bene tutti quanti punti avete
fatto e poi come sempre ci sarà qualcuno
che dirà quanti punti abbiamo fatto fate
dei biglietti
eviterete ammette tutto mentre avete
molto più memore di noi pietri comunque
ora vi lasciamo che a 4 stelle su cui
cliccare e se volete vedere il seconda
parte lasciato un bel like faremo la
seconda fase di slideshow
cliccate su una di queste quattro
cartellini e un buona visione